Endless.
That’s a word you’re likely to hear thrown
around a lot at the SCP Foundation.
Like SCP-3008, known as the Infinite Ikea.
Endless.
Or take the life of the tragically immortal
Dr. Bright, who became one with the SCP-963,
and now is condemned to existing within it
on some level forever.
Endless.
Or most pertinent of all for today’s video,
take SCP-087, a terrifying staircase full
of tangible darkness and a frightening and
unknowable entity.
No matter how far down you go, it seems as
though there’s just another flight, waiting
for you.
Endless.
But really, is anything ever really endless?
Or is endless just the word we use for something
when we haven’t found that sought-after
end just yet?
For those who travel far enough, there may
be a limit to the infinite Ikea.
Someday, Dr. Bright’s medallion one day
might lay inert and lifeless, with no traces
of his consciousness left.
And for those who venture down far enough,
able to clench their teeth and get past the
fear, you may someday find that even SCP-087
has a final flight.
But what if this isn’t just a hypothetical.
What if this has already happened, but the
truth was considered too dangerous or too
horrifying to share?
What’s really at the bottom of SCP-087?
Today, we hope to find out.
Let’s just also hope that knowing doesn’t
end up being more of a burden than we’d
expected…
Before we head to the bottom of the Endless
Staircase though, we must first return to
SCP-087’s file and refresh our memories
on some of the crucial basics.
After all, it’s been quite some time since
our last video on the subject.
This Euclid-Class anomaly is one of the most
well-known and feared, partially thanks to
classified information being leaked via a
certain video game, probably coded by the
Serpent’s Hand.
As we alluded to earlier, many know 087 as
the Endless Staircase, based in an administrative
building of a classified North American university
campus.
It’s been behind a number of mysterious
deaths and disappearances and has left many
of its escaping victims traumatized and in
a state of permanent catatonia.
Having to descend the staircase is just that
terrifying.
Equally infamous as the staircase itself are
the three tests that the Foundation conducted
into the staircase before deciding to just
board up the door forever.
In the first, a D-Class that was once a member
of the Foundation was forced to see just how
many flights he could descend.
Not long after first entering the staircase
and beginning to make his way down, he heard
the desperate and distressed pleas of a child.
He kept descending but found he seemed to
be getting no closer to the source of the
distress.
When he was deep enough, that’s when he
encountered SCP-087-1, a frightening, uncanny
face with few discernible features.
The sheer terror of encountering this entity
was enough to send him running back to the
top.
The second test played out similarly, with
a D-Class being sent in with a number of powerful,
sticky-backed lights that he was ordered to
place against the walls as he descended.
This was done in hopes of increasing visibility
on the staircase.
However, it proved to be unsuccessful, as
the darkness in 087 is more of a tangible
presence than the mere absence of light.
It was able to smother out visibility regardless
of a light source’s power.
Once again, the D-Class heard the crying,
and encountered the face, causing him to flee.
And the third and penultimate test involved
a D-Class who got really unlucky.
She traversed the staircase deeper than any
of her predecessors, before eventually encountering
the horrifying face of SCP-087-1.
However, rather than running up and away from
the entity, in a state of sheer panic, the
D-Class instead ran downwards, deeper and
deeper into the staircase.
The audio cut as the face continued in its
pursuit, and the D-Class was never seen again.
Did you notice that we said “penultimate”
and not “final” before that last one?
That’s because there’s actually a highly
classified fourth expedition into the SCP-087
Staircase, but as you can see on the original
file, the data is expunged.
What could have happened in that study that
led the Foundation to wipe it from the records?
Did they discover the great secret behind
SCP-087, a secret too horrible for mortal
minds to bear?
We’re not just going to give you one answer
today, we’re going to give you three.
That’s right: Three different interpretations
of the secret fourth expedition into SCP-087.
Which is the real one?
Well you’ll just have to see.
After all, nothing is simple when it comes
to SCP-087.
Though our first potential option is the most
simple of the three.
In this iteration of the experiment, a male
D-Class murderer was instructed to descend
the staircase into the heart of SCP-087, with
the Foundation hoping to find out what happened
to D-9884, the female D-Class who’d disappeared
at the conclusion of the third expedition.
In a sense, this new D-Class would discover
the fate that most likely befell D-9884, but
through first-hand experience rather than
distant observation.
Being directed by Dr. Airdo over walkie-talkie,
the male D-Class slowly got deeper into the
anomaly, flight by flight.
Predictably, he began to hear the intensely
distressed crying of a small child around
200 meters below him and immediately felt
a sense of paranoia and dread wash over his
mind.
Despite this, Dr. Airdo ordered him to keep
going, descending deeper and deeper into the
bowels of SCP-087.
Over time, the sheer psychological exhaustion
of SCP-087 was beginning to take its toll
on the D-Class, leading to him taking a brief
break in order to nap.
However, he awoke with a violent start, seeing
the horrific face of SCP-087-1 staring down
at him.
It felt like all his worst nightmares had
come to life.
In order to escape the monster, he began to
flee further down into SCP-087, much like
D-9884 before him.
It would be the last mistake he ever made.
When he finally reached the very bottom of
the 087 staircases, the D-Class realized he
was trapped.
Nowhere to run, nowhere to hide.
Suddenly, the face of SCP-087-1 was hovering
over him again, boring its gaze into him.
As the D-Class directed his powerful flashlight
at the creature, he saw that this time, it
was more than just a face.
The entity had a whole body, seven or eight
feet long, with that same ghostly white and
deathlike appearance.
It reached out with huge, clawed hands and
grasped the D-Class.
Before the audio and video feed cut out entirely,
the last thing the attending researchers heard
was screaming from the hapless D-Class, and
the crunch of his bones within the creature’s
huge hands.
But of course, that’s just one of three
possible insane discoveries at the very bottom
of SCP-087.
Let’s turn our attention to the next one,
and see if its answer to the SCP-087 riddle
seems to satisfy all of our burning questions.
Much like the previous iteration, a single
male D-Class was sent into the clutches of
SCP-087 in hopes of getting some answers on
what happened to D-9884.
Of course, he was given all the standard equipment
- from a 75-watt flashlight to a defensive
weapon to a healthy supply of water and nutrition
bars.
None of which would save him in the end.
Like all the others, this D-Class descended
those accursed stairs, getting deeper and
deeper.
When he reached a certain point on the way
down, he heard something, but not the crying
of a child like all the others had reported.
It was an adult woman’s scream.
Specifically, it was the scream of D-9884,
exactly as the Foundation researchers had
heard it over the audio feed in her last moments
before disappearing.
This was progress.
The researchers instructed this male D-Class
to go deeper, passing flight after flight,
until finally the SCP-087-1 face appeared.
But again, something was different, something
was wrong.
Now, it looked more like the face of D-9884,
just without her mouth and pupils.
Had SCP-087-1 been stealing the faces of its
prior victims?
Had the previous face been stolen from a student
who’d gone missing from the campus?
These were all questions the male D-Class
didn’t have time to ponder, as he was too
busy running for dear life.
But he didn’t get far.
Despite having no history of such medical
problems, the male D-Class suddenly experienced
a seizure while attempting to escape, and
collapsed.
The last thing his video feed picked up before
losing transmission was a pair of long, white
arms emerging from the dark, crushing him
inside of its huge hands, before dragging
his enfolded corpse into the darkness.
That’s another chilling potential account
of the possible fourth expedition into SCP-087,
but we can’t stop now.
We still have one more tale of terror to share
before this video is done.
In the next and final iteration, two D-Classes
- one male and one female - were sent down
together in hopes of discovering what had
happened to D-9884.
And by the end, they would have their answer,
but they certainly wouldn’t like it.
As the two of them descended, they saw the
marks on the wall where the adhesive lights
from expedition two had been somehow torn
off.
But the deeper they descended, the more disturbing
the things they found became.
They discovered words clawed into the stone
walls, each one revealing a piece of a more
frightening puzzle the deeper down SCP-087
they traversed.
They descended further, sustaining minor injuries
from a foul-smelling and caustic substance
left on some of the walls and floors around
them.
At some point along the journey, a light was
dropped, and in the brief seconds of darkness,
the female D-Class disappeared.
The male D-Class was ordered to go deeper
and deeper into the staircase until he finally
began to hear the crying of a little girl.
When he reached the 666th floor, he found
a wooden door, with the word “HOME” scratched
into it.
He steeled himself and entered the room.
But it wasn’t a room at all, it was a field,
shrouded in darkness with a distant tree.
A little girl - the one who had been crying
- was finally, actually here.
She told the D-Class that she’d always been
here, and her father had been trying to find
her a body so she could go “upstairs”,
but for that to happen, she’d have to be
properly birthed first.
That’s when the male D-Class noticed the
two huge stone slabs just beyond the darkness:
On one was the corpse of D-9884, hanged by
her wrists with thick, metal chains.
Her abdomen had been fully cut open, as though
a brutal c-section had been performed on her.
And on the other stone was the female D-Class
who’d been accompanying him this whole time,
strung up but still very much alive - seemingly
the next potential vessel for the little girl’s
rebirth.
But this didn’t mean that the male D-Class
would be left out of the fun, either.
After all, the little girl’s father would
need a new body, too, if he wanted to accompany
his daughter upstairs.
The father in question being SCP-087-1, which
appeared in the room moments later and swooped
in towards the male D-Class.
What followed was a battery of nightmarish
sounds as the darkness expanded and consumed
the field once more.
Not long after this, the Foundation sealed
off the entrance to SCP-087 forever, now knowing
that it potentially contained multiple hostile
entities intent on escaping into our world
and causing further damage.
Students in the area reported a number of
frantic knocks coming from the door for a
brief period after that until the Foundation
finally had it properly soundproofed, and
the issues were seemingly over with.
For now.
So there you have it: Three potential terrifying
secrets at the bottom of SCP-087.
Which do you think is the most likely?
Let us know down in the comments.
After all, when it comes to SCP-087, it seems
you can always delve just a little bit deeper...
Now go check out “SCP-3008 - Trapped in
IKEA” and “SCP-049 - the Plague Doctor
Captured” for more classic SCPs from SCP
Explained!